Film Courage: Well you talk about how you still feel
like you're struggling. To the outside
world it doesn't appear that way and it
appears that you two are doing great. How do you
process rejection? I mean what's your way of dealing with it?
I know you're saying we're doing it for
the love of it and you know but we're
all human beings you all get on this
bipolar ride where we feel badly one day
in this business and then the negative
feel like everybody loves us. Mark Duplass, filmmaker/actor/producer: Yeah
I mean we're really fortunate
right now in that you know we do get
to do stuff. Even though we
get rejected from some things we want to
do, there's always one thing that's got a
"yes" going on and and so I think that
they the best answer we can come up with
is keep a lot of irons in the fire and
it's sort of you play the numbers game a
little bit and it diminishes the
rejections because you have some other
things going on but I think you have to
be smart and be careful about how you
put yourself out there for instance I am
an actor but I don't go out an audition
a lot because it just kills my spirit to
do that you know and it's really hard
and you know we could if we wanted to
engage weekly on these big writing
assignments that are open for for people
to come in and say here's my take on
this job I want to get this job if you
do that you get rejected 49 out of 50
times and then the one that you do get
means you're doing really well but
that's 49 rejections you know so we
don't engage in that process as well so
we just try to protect ourselves to a
certain degree
you know again try to keep a couple of
things going at once in case certain
things burn out it's like dating yes it
said it's just like marriage you need
like you need like five or six wives
yeah
you